jacquel jean paul rouve
personnellement pas là jean talon
serge meyer dalo et ses amis viennent
ils
il a le don pour embrouiller les invités
dire que ça a un coût qui fait le jeu
quand les invités arrivent ici mais
tient démago l'est un but comme ça les
gens si ça c'est pas de l'amour bon jean
paul rouve bonsoir soir bonsoir
alors j'ai une bien belle carrière voilà
merci merci laurence bien pour jean-paul
alors après monsieur batignole podium
reut et un long dimanche de fiançailles
et les clefs de bagnole et les
mouvements alors si tu cites les grands
films c'est vrai c'est vrai on vous
retrouve dans un petit jeu sans
conséquence de bernard rapp et là vous
êtes moins bien car je sais pas à la
chute la drogue je crois plutôt 700 avec
sandrine kiberlain marina follis yvan
attal et lionel abelanski sortie le 15
décembre à la hanche et le pitch
invasive asie on va voir bien le pitch
en général yvan attal vie avec sandrine
kiberlain importe quoi il avec charlotte
g échappe à la basse et voilà ça fait le
beach moderne rend le pitch moderne dans
l'ancien pitch on dit à l'ats serge
marchand comprendre dans le pitch
moderne on donne le nom de l'acteur
comme protagoniste du film c'est le
pitch d'aujourd'hui l'antre voilà en
clivant attal effectivement est avec
sandrine kiberlain
c'est le pitch black ali n'est pas dans
la vraie sur l'autre bien cela dit
baisse tous un peu ensemble showbiz 1-1
va savoir son vivant l'un tient avec
avec sandrine kiberlain depuis douze ans
et au cours d'une journée dans une
propriété à la campagne tous les proches
sont sont conviés ils font semblant par
jeu de se séparer
et là c'est horrible circuit découvre
que personne ne croit à leur couple et
tout le monde leur dis bah oui
finalement effectivement on attend frein
on n'a jamais compris pourquoi vous
étiez ensemble c'est mieux comme ça et
tout donc ils découvrent que personne
n'y croit et si terrible parce que ce
petit jeu sans conséquence a des
conséquences c'est à dire qu'à un moment
marina foïs dit à sandrine kiberlain
qu'elle a couché avec son jules avec
avec yvan attal donc évidemment ça jette
un froid il dit maintenant non vous êtes
séparés je peux te le dire je me le suis
tapé donc tu imagines corps nabeul et
vous jean paul rouve qui est l'ennemi
dans onze yvan attal meilleur est à son
meilleur ennemi elle est poussée dans
les temps même si vous dites le
contraire pendant tout le film mais
aussi les signes nous crever l'oeil on
sent qu'à une vieille haine qui rôdent
en entre vous deux et vous draguez
sandrine kiberlain voilà et est donc ce
petit jeu sans conséquence et plein de
conséquence je ne dirais pas la fin mais
ça vaut le coup c'est une une belle
histoire ça commence comme ça comme un
dimanche à la campagne puis ça s'est
remis d'une façon assez assez amer ac
est grand c'est ça oui un don qui
divorcent
non si la france est pas bon c'est
rapide je peux pas dire non mais je veux
pas dire fais pas dire je veux pas dire
je veux pas dire voilà alors il ya une
scène il ya beaucoup de scènes vous êtes
formidables il ya une scène soul a sous
la gloriette vous fait rire semblent
minimes vers la gt excellent merci
thierry même un excellent si gentil non
mais moi je vous avais dit a longtemps
dû trouver un très bon acteur
et là vous êtes sur les traces des
meilleurs acteurs français vos modèles
bravia un quart est gilbert michel simon
va vous êtes peut-être très bon parce
que dans ce film situé il et il n'est
pas vraiment sympa quoi j'ai appuyé un
peu cynique
ouais ouais c'est un séducteur ça prend
une fois que je joue ça donc c'est
intéressant ces personnages très ambigus
comme ça le manipulateur séducteur très
bien écrit sur ce gimmick voir acteurs
c'est génial à jouer quoi sert à tisser
une adaptation pièce c'est une question
de pièces voilà tu 5 molière ouais
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que c'est réaliser
d'une façon très humble
c'est à dire que bernard hachemi
vraiment au service de la pièce quoi ya
pas de fioritures simplement il montre
les acteurs du secteur voient la tournée
il y six tournées c'est à dire que les
scènes on le faisait dans la continuité
ou faisait beaucoup de plans séquences
assez intéressant pour
pour l'heure fois que je travaillais
comme ça maintenant deuxième 10e fois
très précis quand tu as raison toujours
fait référence à son fils quoi confirmer
voilà je crois que da complet j'ai
contrôlé être acceptée ça y est j'y suis
c'est le lancement voilà c'était c'est
tellement agréable à faire mais ensemble
nous y voilà du plaisir beaucoup de
plaisir beaucoup de plaisir ce que ça
change voix c'est toujours la même chose
quand ce n'est pas une chose que podium
donc un an ça qui me plaît dans le
métier d'acteur
un peu comme ce que je faisais avec une
bagnole tu vois c'est le personnage que
je raffole
est ce que tu vas faire tu va regarder
ta caméra l'épisode est la dernière
partie à dire en bois parce que là c'est
pas possible c'est là qu'elle a le rouge
aux joues et tu dis magnéto serge comme
les autres ni d'accord magnéto serge